I got
a
mar ex the parking
lot seing Target
vehicle copy thank you we have a new
vehicle unidentified at this
time this is is pretty typical you
either a driver swap or the addition of
another another person involved in in
the transportation so um this is a good
good
sign if those narcotics get transferred
into this other vehicle we're all set up
in positions for for a takedown
targ just
popped a go go go
go please hands up
don't move don't
move how
[Music]
you apprehended the the secondary driver
and the original
[Music]
driver how many how many packages were
moved into the new this is everything
this is everything as we found it oh
that's a yeah he got quite a bit out
already so this is all that was already
transferred
into into the other vehicle from the
original
vehicle I'm going to keep those isolated
so we have them documented but then
we're going to consolidate them so
they're on one
spot so right now we're just getting a
account on all the packages make sure
that we have a good accountability for
what we got so that's
13 of that
now we're just essentially processing
the scene I'm going to try to interview
everybody involved and see uh they can
make any statements about their
involvement and if they were hold on one
sec guys actually we're going to move on
what's going on we think some more
people are coming to retrieve this so
we're going to get out of the
area go go go our minutes are taking
away you just need to be ready for
whatever happen since
[Music]
nexts